(city traffic passing)
(gentle music)
- What's interesting
about fear and excuses
is if you reverse engineer them backward
to the seed of where it's coming from,
it means that a stunning majority of
the people in this audience
are actually tied up
in caring about somebody
else's point of view on them
and I'm really fascinated by that.
Fear's holding you back.
You know what you wanna do.
The only reason you're not doing
it is 'cause you're scared
of doing what you actually wanna do.
So, what are you scared of, failing?
- [Man] Um, not failing but
still being at the same place
when my friends are at the next level.
- Huge mistake.
You don't want the same
thing your friends want
so why the (profanity) do
you care what they have?
Number one mistake so many people make
is they care about what other people have.
I don't give a (profanity)
what anybody has.
If I have more, I have
less, it doesn't matter.
I worry about myself.
The fact that you're worrying
about other people's accomplishments
is already a losing formula.
You need to get rid of that first,
then you can focus on yourself.
(gentle music)
I would argue
that well more than 50% of the people
in this audience
are here today
because they worry about the way
they would be judged
by one and or two family members
in their inner seven, eight people circle.
If you're not feeling'
it, find new friends.
I'm being dead serious about this.
This one is real big for me.
Who you hang out with is a huge deal.
And again, these are all
tried and true things, right?
We've heard the, "You're the
whatever of the five friends."
Like, that's real.
Add one new winner friend.
Like, you know what I mean?
Add one new winner friend
and cut one loser friend.
Like, yeah,
I know he's been your
boy since fourth grade
but he sits at home and (profanity)
smokes weed and plays 2K all day.
Like, you can only love him so much.
(gentle music)
And to me, that is the most fascinating
thing that's happening
as I'm going through my journey,
which is, Oh,
the reason I am
capable and have the luxury
of standing up here
is that my parents parented me in a way
that gave me so much
self esteem while respect
When I was nine years old and
opened the door
for an elderly woman
at a McDonald's
she reacted as if
I won the Nobel Peace Prize.
(laughter from audience)
What my Mom did was super smart,
she overreacted on
everything that I was doing
that was a good human trait.
My Mom built huge self esteem in me
and I feel like the biggest reason
I am who I am today to everybody
is 'cause I feel so guilty
and so grateful
for what she did for me
that I wanna do it for everybody else.
Which is guess what?
You suck at a ton of (profanity).
Good, so does everybody else.
You're also probably pretty
rad at something.
Try as many things
as possible until you
figure out what you're rad at,
and you like,
and go do that
for the rest of your life,
and stop giving a (profanity)
about everybody else
(Applause)
There's just an incredible, y'know,
like kinda axis point of like
what you're great at and what you love.
When you stumble into
being somebody like me,
you really win.
When what you're naturally great at
is what you naturally love the most,
and away you go.
So I think what you need to do
is taste everything, it's kinda like food,
you don't know what your favorite food is
if you only eat one food.
So I would take advantage of your youth
and your flexibility at this kind of age
and try to taste everything
play with everything
figure out what you might be good at
what you might like
and then you make a decision.
(gentle music)
It's a very fine balance.
I don't stand up here
not giving a (profanity)
about what people think about me.
It's just that
I care just a little bit
more about what I think
about myself than everybody else combined.
(Applause and cheering from audience)
And I just think a lot
of people are crippled by
going on the offense
because we are sold defense
we are sold defense
we just are.
Offense is always the best defense.
Offense always solves problems,
as long as your defense is
not a complete disaster,
so, I just think offense
is a very good mentality.
There is a trigger mindset,
I'm always trying to stay in offense.
Same I always say,
same I hear from everybody who wins.
You know, I think the
fear of losing trumps
the excitement of victory
for so many people
I think people are so scared.
Nobody wants the rejection.
Nobody wants to lose.
So, I understand the philosophy.
I understand that string of DNA
that doesn't wanna make you lose
but I'm so desperate to figure out
how to convince people that
there is no loss in going for it
that, yeah you might get made fun of
and you might have it in your own mind but
trying to figure out how to make people
drop that fear of going and building
a business for themselves
in 2012
Trying to figure out how to make a video
or give a talk, or send a tweet
or
write a book
just something that
makes me understand that
executing the way it always is
is going to lead you to a place
where you're not going to win.
Life's funny bro.
And I think that a lot of people
are sitting here for another reason
in those two. Fear and judgment of others.
This one I'm obsessed with
if you're following me
I just think most of you lack patience.
I tell these 23 year olds, 26 year olds
all the time to be patient.
Because they should.
How old are you?
- 44
- Think of it, I'm 40, do
you know how young we feel?
It's.. when you were
26, did you ever think
that this was what 44 felt like?
- [Man 2] No.
- You thought that that was finished.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Like, you think a 40
year old's like (mumbles)
When I was 25 years old
I thought a 40 year old
was finished.
I don't even feel like I'm starting.
It's a balance of regret and patience.
You can go hard for three years,
do nothing right, wake up,
and be young as (profanity).
You should really go to
a retirement home one day
and volunteer just talk to them.
It will make you want to do (profanity)
every minute of your life.
Because when you see regret in a mans eyes
it's (profanity) painful.
Because you can't do (profanity) about it.
When you're 90, and you're not mobile,
and you're (profanity)
tired and it's over,
you can't do it, you can't do it,
you can't build that company you wanted,
you can't spend that time with your kid.
It's regret.
And it (profanity) drives
the (profanity) out of me.
I think that patience
has been the
disproportionate component of my success.
- [Narrator] So what
should we do, Garyvee?
Let's wrap this up.
What should we do?
What should people do?
- [Garyvee] People
should stop complaining.
People should figure out who
the (profanity) they are.
- [Narrator] Good call.
- [Garyvee] People should not
listen to America Propaganda
of fixing the (profanity) they suck at
they should be tripling down on what
they're good at.
They should be competent in certain areas
but you're not gonna become Beyonce
or like, you know, your bone structure
is a certain way.
Like, you're not gonna solve everything.
Your IQ can get a little bit better
but don't worry about the incremental.
Figure out what puts you on fire
and you're halfway decent at.
If you're lucky enough
right now to be listening
and you're good at what you like
become tunnel vision.
Because there's way too many voices
telling you what and how
and here's the other thing,
and this is the big one, Joe.
Have the conversation
with the person that's holding you back.
The reason most people who
are listening right now
are not doing that thing
is they're worried about
the opinion of somebody,
usually, their mother.
Usually, their father.
And the reality is, is that your spouse
may be the person holding you back,
and you have to have that conversation.
- [Narrator] Cut 'em off!
- [Garyvee] We have to get to a place
where you're doing you
because the number one thing that scares
the (profanity) out of me is regret.
And you're gonna sit there at 72
and you're gonna say 'I
wish, I wish, I wish',
and whether that's money,
or spending more time with your family,
there's a million ways to do this.
Not everybody wants to buy the jets,
not everybody wants to
smoke weed on the beach
in the Bahamas.
Everybody's got a different thing,
figure out what your (profanity) thing is
and stop making (profanity) excuses.
Who the President is,
your Mom did this,
like, like, I missed it, oh
I had that idea for Uber,
then why didn't you (profanity) do it?
There's a reason that
guys and gals like me
continue to have audiences
because people want to be motivated
to go and do things
or they wanna learn tactics
to go and do things.
But, whether I'm giving
you tactical advice
like filters on Snapchat
or Facebook ads,
or Instagram story collaborations,
or I'm motivating you through my words
because I communicate that way,
or through my actions
seeing this wake up at five, (mumbles).
If everybody who's watching this
actually did something about it
and then went on the course of
their version of it
then they wouldn't be watching this
and I genuinely know at
the bottom of my heart
out of all the people that
want to build audiences
that I'm the complete opposite
of almost all of them.
Because, 99% of people that
produce content like this
that are out there like I am
the business of being
that is what they are.
I have businesses.
I have (mumbles name of business).
I don't need your 14 bucks for my book.
Or to be in my course
or this and that.
So I don't need to monetise you
so I,
then,
genuinely want you
to never watch me again.
The problem is,
every time you guys are posting...
Do you know how many times I see on my
Instagram 'oh I needed this today'?
And do you know how many
times I see that person
nine months later still hanging around?
If you needed it, then take
it and do something about it.
The reason there's going to be a billion
motivational views today on YouTube
is that people love the
feeling of being motivated
they don't like putting in the work
to do something about the feeling.
I hate the motivation me.
Until you do something about it.
(peaceful music)